My hope is that in listening to either book people find it
reassuring that so many of the people they might put on a pedestal have all the
same problems.
They do.
It's not that they succeed because they lack and securities or lack
problems or lack self-defeating habits.
It's that they've figured out how to manage those things.
These world-class performers don't have super powers. The rules they've cracked.
Crafted for themselves,
allow the bending of reality to such an extent that it might seem that way,
but they've learned how to do this. And so can you,
these so-called rules are often uncommon habits in bigger cases.
So if you want to change your life significantly,
you want to change your business or career significantly.
You want to change how you relate to other people. Significantly.
The magic is really in the questions.
These two books can give you not just a set of toolkit of better
questions,
but the increased ability to craft questions of your own.
They get you the results you want. And that is as close to a superpower,
as I think is possible in a surprising number of cases,
the power is in the absurd, the marble.
The more impossible, the question, the more profound the answers take,
for instance, a question that serial billionaire,
Peter teal likes to ask himself and others.
If you have a ten-year plan of how to get somewhere, you should ask,
why can't you do this in six months for purposes of illustration here,
I might reword that to what might you do to accomplish your tenure goals in the
next year.
Six months, if you had a gun against your head,
I do recommend that everybody pursue, if they can,
the bare bones of drawing, let's say the bare bones of music,
just so they develop greater sensitivity in seeing and hearing and
listening because that transfers to everything.
Number one is 20 minutes of seated meditation in the morning.
Number two would be journaling in some short form,
isolating the things that are most important to get done that day,
the big dominoes to tip over,
or if you're feeling really stressed out morning pages from Julia Cameron. Very,
very helpful. Then if I had to pick a third, I would say
a short bout of exercise. If I check those three boxes,
every day feels more in control.